ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Cloud Console
is our powerful,
all-in-one graphical tool
to manage your Google Cloud
Platform resources, regardless
of their data center location.
In this video, we'll
cover the core features
to get you ready
to build and manage
your applications on GCP.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GCP resources are the
fundamental components
that make up the
Google Cloud Services.
Typical examples
include Compute Engine
virtual machines,
Cloud Pub/Sub topics,
cloud storage buckets, App
Engine instances, and so forth.
Resources are organized
hierarchically
using projects and folders.
Projects allow to
group resources
together and are the first
level of that hierarchy.
All resources must belong
to exactly one project.
So a given virtual machine
or Kubernetes engine cluster
belongs to one project.
Optionally, projects can
belong to organizations,
and provide centralized
visibility and control
across all projects
in a given org.
You can further organize your
company departments or teams
into folders.
Folders can contain both
projects and subfolders
for added flexibility.
This entire hierarchy
offers an ownership chain,
which means that when
you delete a parent,
all its resources
are also deleted.
It also provides the basis
for access control policy
inheritance.
You can easily navigate
across your GCP projects
using the scope picker
in Cloud Console.
Switching projects
will tailor the view
to that project and all
of its child resources.
GCP services are accessible
in the left-hand navigation
menu, organized by product area,
including big data, compute,
networking, and so forth.
The home dashboard provides
a high-level overview
of the selected GCP
project, highlighting
key metrics, billing, and
other useful information.
You can customize
your dashboard freely.
Any card can be hidden, shown,
and reordered on the page.
With the Activity
Stream, you'll be
able to understand all
the activities that
occur across your GCP
resources in one place.
You can see which
projects have been
updated, what your
teammates are doing,
or audit access to
your GCP resources.
You can also filter
through the feed
to find exactly what you need.
The search bar in Cloud Console
allows you to quickly access
Google Cloud Platform products
and any of your resources
across GCP.
Simply search for App
Engine or the name
of one of your projects.
The APIs and Services
section of the Console
is where you can manage one
of our hundreds of APIs,
enable or disable a service,
generate or revoke credentials,
monitor requests, and so forth.
This includes all of our GCP,
machine learning, Google Maps,
G Suite, and Analytics APIs.
If you ever get
stuck or need help
navigating the world of GCP, our
support team is here to help.
Your support cases relating
to both development questions
and production issues
are all accessible right
from the Console
navigation menu.
Google Cloud Identity and
Access Management, or Cloud IAM,
enables you to manage
and create permissions
for your GCP resources.
As your team grows,
you can grant access
to teammates using the
IAM and Admin section.
Add users, groups,
or service accounts,
and assign them
any number of roles
to grant them the
permission they need.
As you can see, there
are many predefined roles
to choose from, not just
admin and developer.
Google Cloud Shell provides
you with command line access
to your cloud resources
directly from your browser.
You can easily manage your
projects and resources
without having to install
anything on your system.
Cloud Shell is accessible
right from your browser
in Cloud Console, and is powered
by a small virtual machine
with persistent disk space and
up-to-date software for all
of your development needs.
It even comes with a web editor.
The billing section
of the cloud console
is where you manage
billing accounts
and link your projects to them.
A billing account is
essentially a payment method--
one or more credit card
information or bank
account details.
A project that does not
have billing enabled--
that means it does not have any
associated billing account--
will just not be able
to use GCP products
beyond their free tiers.
You can change the
billing account
for a given project
at any point in time.
You can set budget alerts
to help you manage costs,
and set up triggered actions for
projects or accounts, as well.
You can also generate
billing exports, as well as
reports to better
understand your spend.
Finally, Cloud Console is also
available as a free mobile app
for both Android and iOS.
It can help you understand
the health of your services
at a glance with
customizable graphs--
CPU, network usage,
QPS, and so forth--
and show you any billing alerts.
It allows you to manage
incidents and alerts,
navigate through error
and crash reports.
You can also start and stop
Compute Engine instances,
navigate through their logs,
and even SSH into them.
Other products such as
App Engine, Cloud Storage,
and Cloud SQL are
also supported.
I can't wait to see what you
build next with Cloud Console.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.